hi there Steve here today I'm gonna take
a break from the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People although the series
will continue or I expound on each of
these habits today I want to talk about
public speaking it comes up a lot it's a
wonderful way to practice your skills in
a foreign language it is in some ways
related to how we organize our thoughts
even when writing I went to see aa nice
security tooth politique in Paris where
they put out tremendous emphasis on how
we organize our thoughts one teacher
once told me laughs from a prison
protocol to new form is more important
than content when you're public speaking
I think the best basic mm approach to
public speaking is to follow the
practice of the old Greeks and Romans I
go into some detail on this in a lesson
from our linked library or you can find
the text and the audio if you're
learning English and I'm gonna put a
link to it here in the description and
to touch upon it here very quickly the
basic principles were as follows
when you are giving a speech and of
course the old Greeks and Romans oratory
rhetoric was very important they were
often defending people in court or
whatever our politicians basic
principles are you begin by getting
people to like you so therefore it is
often a good thing to kind of maybe
spill your glass of water or have
trouble adjusting your microphone so
that people like you you're human or you
recognize someone in the audience and
say it's very nice to be here again with
my good friend so-and-so and so on so
first thing you get people to like you
the second thing is you establish your
credentials why should they listen to
you because I have this experience or
that experience so you establish your
credentials the third thing is to tell a
story people like to hear stories they
don't want to be browbeaten with a bunch
of arguments they want a picture created
for them so you still tell a story that
relate to the subject at hand
then the fourth thing is you set out
your main argument now they like you
they consider you credible you've
painted a bit of a picture and now you
present your argument you can then
present a counter-argument you know but
on the other hand hey some of you may
say something else and then of course
you follow that up by destroying the
counter-argument and then you finish off
with an emotional appeal all right and
these are you won't remember them all
they're described in this article that I
provided a link to whenever I use this
I'm in control almost in I'm in control
of the feelings and and almost the
reactions it's not manipulating but I
have some sense I know where I'm leading
my listeners they don't know where
they're going and and it is actually
quite effective you gain the sympathy
and then you gain the interest because
they find you credible because you tell
a story and then you hit them with the
main message you suggest a possible
counter-argument you demolish the
counter-argument and you end off with an
emotional appeal to action let's say and
that's basically in a nutshell but you
can read up on it if you look if you
google there is universities I think
Tufts University has a series on
rhetoric or you can simply go to the
article that I've posted here in the
description so there you have it public
speaking and of course be confident and
and enjoy yourself and it's a great way
to practice your language skills bye for
now